[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a des rendez-vous à ne pas manquer
dans les coulisses de l'Olympia la
musique de la Légion étrangère se
prépare à un concert qui fera date de
Jacques Brel à Lady Gaga en passant par
les Rolling Stones les plus grands
artistes se sont produits dans cette
salle mythique ce jour-là c'est au tour
des légionnaires la musique de la Légion
étrangère fait partie des 11 formations
musicales professionnelles du ministère
des armées elle est originale à plus
d'un titre notamment pour la
particularité de son recrutement
ce sont des légionnaires qui ont même
qui ont suivi le même le même parcours
le même la même démarche de de tous ces
de 9000 autres la seule différence c'est
qu'ils ont un ils sont doués ils ont un
don soit parce qu'ils l'ont découvert à
tardivement soit parce que c'était des
professionnels avant dans leur pays
d'origine pour la musique ils ont des
qualités qu'on détecte parfois très tôt
ou que le chef de musique détecte un peu
plus tard quoi qu'il en soit ce sont de
vrais légionnaires qui font des papes
d'entraînement qui font aussi des
missions sentinelles certains ou même
servi plusieurs années en unité
opérationnelle
donc j'étais théorique c'est une arme
antichard et avec ça je participe
avec cette régiment
servir dans les compagnies combat avec
les jeunesse
de ma vie à certains que je peux me
parler une seule montre donc aujourd'hui
actuellement je suis chef de pépites
d'harmonie j'ai passé sous-officier sur
le niveau des scènes de musique dans les
étrangère avoir sur 60 musiciens j'ai
aujourd'hui 17 nationalités différentes
des parcours complètement atypiques des
gens qui quittent leur famille leur pays
leur racine donc ils arrivent là il faut
il faut s'en occuper il faut être avec
eux et ça c'est inestimable donc faut on
les perçoit on va chercher la
sensibilité à travers la musique c'est
pareil quand on chante on distingue tous
les timbres de voix des des par rapport
aux nationalités
et quand il s'exprime en chantant ou en
jouant ben c'est leur tripes qui sort et
ben voilà donc ils ont cette Ferté
d'appartenir à la légion et ça c'est
pour ça que je dis c'est pas la
meilleure musique mais c'est la plus
belle
[Musique]
une exception humaine qui se retrouve
autour d'un langage universel la musique
depuis la création de la Légion
étrangère en 1831 ces artistes
militaires font rayonner à un précieux
patrimoine musical habitué aux
représentations de prestige ils vont
cette fois-ci récolter des fonds afin
d'aider les anciens et les blessés ainsi
que leur famille un nouveau défi pour
ces hommes habitués à enlever et à
quelques minutes d'entrer en scène les
coeurs s'emballe
[Musique]
tellement puissante vous sortez les
forces de chacun
chaque homme qui est à vos côtés donc ça
va mieux encore ça vaut donc plus de
courage pour pour continuer
du courage il en faudra ils sont très
attendus mélomane fan de la Légion venu
entre amis ou en famille ils ont parfois
fait des centaines de kilomètres pour
assister à ce concert
pendant deux heures les képi blancs vont
offrir le spectacle de leur vie en
alliant répertoire militaire et chansons
populaires sur cette scène légendaire
ils vont raconter un instrument à la
main l'épopée de Monsieur légionnaire de
son engagement à sa formation militaire
sans oublier ses coups de blues avec une
interprétation bouleversante d'un
extrait de la bande originale de La
Liste de Schindler
[Musique]
puis il y a les permissions à Paris
bercées par Edith Piaf un moment
suspendu que les musiciens partagent
avec la chanteuse Nathalie Lhermitte
[Musique]
ce soir les légionnaires au tout jusqu'à
un rap audacieux qui reprend un thème
très connu
[Musique]
un final en apothéose pour ses musiciens
et pour leur chef qui clôturent sa
carrière après 43 ans sous les drapeaux
la musique militaire n'a pas toujours
été en haut de la fiche pour le
comprendre il faut remonter le temps
d'abord j'en musical elle est
progressivement devenue aussi une
formation instrumentale
la musique militaire a servi de tout
temps à transmettre des ordres d'abord
sur les champs de bataille bien sûr et
mais aussi dans la vie au quartier entre
guillemets par des batteries des
sonneries au fur et à mesure son nez
vraiment des formations militaires dans
la renaissance après l'époque de Louis
XIV ou les structures les orchestres se
structures c'était essentiellement la
Révolution française que les musiques
militaires prennent leur essor avec
notamment la création de l'Institut
National de Musique qui est à l'origine
fondée pour former des musiciens
militaires on a eu jusqu'à une dizaine
de classes de clarinettes de bassons etc
d'instruments avant au Conservatoire de
Paris au 19e siècle c'est l'apport des
instruments d'Adolph sax facteur belge
qui va faire évoluer énormément les
orchestres militaires avec l'apport des
saxophones et des saxornes qui vont être
considérablement développer le son de
ces ensembles militaires c'est
l'orchestre militaires pendant la
Première Guerre mondiale les musiciens
militaires sont utilisés comme souvent
en tant que guerre commettent au service
médical comme brancardier notamment et
puis seront utilisés évidemment comme
emploi de cérémonial et également et
surtout comme outil de soutien de moral
des troupes la musique militaires est un
outil du passé qui est transmet un
répertoire une histoire des tenues et
qui également est tourné vers l'avenir
la musique d'aujourd'hui les musiques
modernes des musiques récentes comme
d'ailleurs les musiques militaires l'ont
toujours fait
vecteur de mobilisation au combat de
prestige plus de divertissement la place
de la musique n'a cessé d'évoluer une
diversité d'emplois qui continue de
séduire chaque année des dizaines de
musiciens professionnels sont
sélectionnés pour intégrer les
formations militaires
c'est le cas de Victor 28 ans il vient
de rejoindre la musique des
parachutistes de Toulouse l'ambassadrice
des troupes aéroportées de l'armée de
terre musiciens depuis l'âge de 8 ans et
ancienne élève du conservatoire du Havre
il est aujourd'hui militaire durant il
se souvient de cette audition
particulièrement sélective pour vivre de
sa passion la clarinette
[Musique]
ça se fait d'abord par l'avis de
concours en fait auquel on doit répondre
envoyer un dossier avec CV lettre de
motivation et si notre profil peut
convenir on est invité à passer un
concours musical et ça ça se passe en
général en une ou deux étapes on arrive
ici on a une phase de chauffe
préparation et on arrive après devant le
devant le jury où on doit jouer une
pièce qu'on a qu'on a préparé ou deux ça
dépend des années de concours et un
morceau de déchiffrage avant de
d'entamer un entretien qui a été assez
approfondie pour savoir si notre profil
peut correspondre
[Musique]
on est bien content de voir de gens
candidats qui sont très dynamiques et
qui sont encore dans un cursus d'études
pour amener à la fois de l'énergie de la
bonne humeur au sein du pupitre en
particulier et puis généralement dans
l'orchestre et comme dans n'importe quel
entreprise on a aussi un petit peu
besoin de cerner les personnes savoir un
petit peu ce qui pense de même ceux qui
comment est-ce qu'ils peuvent se
projeter dans notre orchestre comment
voilà on essaie de connaître un petit
peu notre nouveau futur nouvelle recrue
pour les dirigés le lieutenant Mathieu
Larrieu le chef de musique un rôle
essentiel au sein des musiques
militaires puisqu'il disposent d'une
double casquette chef d'orchestre et
commandant d'unités sélection des
morceaux gestion du personnel
préparation des événements il veille
chaque jour à l'excellence du groupe on
va commencer avec célébrité
[Musique]
alors nos activités au quotidien
imposent de recruter des musiciens de de
haut niveau puisque
nous sommes depuis la
professionnalisation des armées des
orchestres à 100% professionnel donc
spécialistes
ce qui implique que nous passons
l'essentiel de notre temps à préparer
des représentations des cérémonies des
concerts parfois dans des délais
relativement restreints ce qui impose
donc d'avoir des musiciens qui soient
très réactifs et qui est au niveau de
compétence donc notre cible pour le
recrutement c'est essentiellement les
conservatoires
46 musiciens composent la musique des
parachutistes avant de rejoindre
l'orchestre chacun suit une FGI une
formation générale initiale de quelques
mois dans un centre militaire
[Applaudissements]
une obriste une farinettiste et un
tromboniste ont été retenus pour cette
séquence voilà comme tout militaire on
est on peut être appelé n'importe quand
pour une cérémonie d'accueil inopiné du
président qui se déplace juste à côté de
jour après ou des honneurs funèbres
aussi ça arrive c'est vrai que un
musicien qui sort du Conservatoire on
lui apprend pendant tout son cursus
artistique à sortir des cases à
s'exprimer aller au-delà de des cadres
et arriver ici dans l'institution
militaire on a beaucoup de cadres de
règles de hiérarchie de donc au début ça
peut un peu dérouter alors on essaye
que chacun puisse s'épanouir
artistiquement on peut avoir un musicien
qui est passionné de hard rock et qui ne
peut pas exprimer pleinement cette
passion dans la musique militaire mais
qui va pouvoir l'exprimer à l'extérieur
dans un autre groupe civil le fait de
pouvoir mener une double vie parfois
fait que l'équilibre peut se trouver
assez facilement et ça je pense que ça
constitue un avantage assez intéressant
pour les musiciens
pour l'instant ça m'apporte beaucoup de
stabilité musicale déjà ce qui est
important pour un musicien surtout en
finissant les études de pouvoir se
produire vraiment régulièrement d'être
pris en charge dans une structure
professionnelle c'est vraiment des
choses qui sont importantes on est
vraiment comme entre guillemets
n'importe quel musicien sauf que
effectivement on a ce statut militaire
qui nous
oblige à certaines à certaines choses
[Musique]
cette rigueur militaire rythme également
le quotidien de la musique de l'Air et
de l'Espace créée en 1936 elle est
installée sur la base aérienne 107 de
Villacoublay en région parisienne avec
110 musiciens tous lauréat du
Conservatoire National Supérieur de
Paris ou de Lyon elle fait partie des
plus prestigieuses formations musicales
des armées c'est un orchestre militaire
qui donc représente autant que faire ce
peu et le plus souvent possible notre
institution et joue son rôle
d'ambassadeur tente à travers la
première mission des cérémonies
militaires et ou protocolaire et ainsi
que des concerts soit caritatifs comme
celui de ce soir soit des concerts dans
des pour les bases aériennes des
concerts pour l'autorité militaire ou
des concerts dans des festivals de
musique
[Musique]
la musique de l'air est un ambassadeur
de l'Armée de l'Air c'est-à-dire qu'elle
se produit le plus souvent possible dans
des salles de concert dans des théâtres
comme celui-ci elle se produit le plus
souvent possible pour à la fois divertir
mais à travers nos prestations musicales
véhiculer l'image et les valeurs de
l'Armée de l'Air la rigueur des
répétitions la fréquence des répétitions
et l'exigence artistique de tous les
jours
nous pensons que c'est le meilleur moyen
de de véhiculer cette image de rigueur
et d'excellence notre rôle nous de chef
de musique et d'encadrant avec mes
adjoints c'est de d'entretenir cette
exigence de la magnifier et surtout de
développer le travail de cohérence de
travail d'ensemble la cohésion tout
simplement
tous musiciens que ce soit qui soit
militaires ou non travail à partir du
moment où les gens se détendent
généralement donc c'est un choix qui est
fait c'est un choix qui est fait aussi
avec la vie de famille c'est aussi de
des émotions partagées c'est des moments
un peu uniques un peu suspendus des fois
et c'est ce qu'on recherche quand on est
musicien je crois
l'orchestre militaire accompagne
régulièrement les grandes cérémonies des
aviateurs sur cette place d'armes dans
le sud de la France les musiciens n'ont
pas le droit à l'erreur chaque musique
chaque déplacement chaque seconde compte
cette représentation millimétrée
illustre un protocole maîtrisé à la
perfection
il y a cérémonie de baptême de promotion
des élèves officiers de l'armée de la
reine de l'espace à sans vous Provence
sur la base aérienne 701 c'est une
cérémonie importante avant tout pour les
jeunes élèves cette cérémonie est
présidée par notre chef le chef
d'état-major en armée de la reine
l'espace le général Stéphane millle
c'est une cérémonie qui est très
importante pour les pour les officiers
qui ça marque un tournant dans leur
carrière la porte d'une musique avec des
musiciens plutôt qu'un CD apporte une
solennité à ces moments-là qui qui est
très très importante
lors des déplacements la musique nous
aide à marcher ou pas à rester
synchroniser à garder nos alignements à
garder nos bras tendus et en somme elle
rythme nos pas et c'est quelque chose de
réellement stimulant et je pense que la
musique de l'air rajoute une dimension
autre dimension vraiment très solennelle
dans notre série
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis que l'on rentre en école de
formation jusqu'à jusqu'à
jusqu'à maintenant et durant toutes les
cérémonies que l'on à laquelle on peut
assister la musique est présente que ça
soit à travers les champs les champs qui
renforcent la cohésion qui nous
permettent de marcher correctement au
paka dansé et lors des cérémonies qui
rittent la vie du militaire il y a cette
adage qui veut que qu'un bon soldat est
d'abord un beau soldat et justement la
musique nous aide à cela comme toute
prestation il y a toute une préparation
technique
musicale donc avec du travail séquencé
par pupitre ou par groupe du travail en
répétition générale les mouvements aussi
puissent quand on se déplace ça
nécessite beaucoup de rigueur c'est
décupler c'est encore plus difficile
lorsque on est en nocturne et donc sans
trop de repères visuels les marches
militaires ont ce site particulier c'est
la structure de la marche tant sur le
plan rythmique que sur le plan de des
mélodies c'est quelque chose de très
symétrique et donc qui permet les
déplacements
protocole et cérémonies ne représentent
qu'une partie du quotidien de ces
musiciens
la musique militaire c'est aussi être
festive et populaire
[Musique]
en Normandie le baguette de Lann-Bihoué
donne l'aubade à l'Armada de Rouen cette
fête réunit tous les quatre à six ans
pendant 10 jours une quarantaine de
voiliers et de bâtiments militaires
français et étrangers difficile de le
rater sa musique joyeuse rassemble
aussitôt du monde
[Musique]
on était venu déjà en 2019 c'était des
supers souvenirs d'ailleurs il rencontre
les bateaux tout ça il y a beaucoup de
choses c'est un bouillon de culture du
coup nous on est hyper content de
revenir déjà on a des souvenirs déjà
qu'on commence à se remémorer là quand
on arrive sur le site donc c'est super
chouette
le quartier maître maeleg dirige depuis
près de 2 ans cet ensemble de musique
traditionnelle bretonne
issues de la Marine nationale son titre
Penner en breton autrement dit chef
d'orchestre
c'est une chance quelque part d'être
responsable de musiciens qui sont qui
sont incroyables on s'entend super bien
non c'est une super expérience c'est
génial vraiment
le bagad compte 30 musiciens
professionnels des soners parmi lesquels
des joueurs de bombarde de cornemuse de
caisse claire et de percussions
militaires il signe un contrat d'un nom
avec la Marine nationale renouvelable 4
fois agimite 30 ans moyenne d'âge 24
joueuse de caisse claire depuis l'âge de
8 ans le matelot Yuna a choisi
d'auditionner aux bagades après ses
études c'est sa première année
et puis mais on enchaîne vraiment le
rythme et de l'été est arrivé entre les
festivals où les voyages qu'on a pu
faire à l'étranger donc on est parti à
aux États-Unis pour un tatou militaire à
Norfolk 10 jours et ensuite on a eu la
chance d'embarquer sur le Dixmude qui a
un porte hélicoptère pendant trois
semaines pour faire du rayonnement donc
on a fait Nouméa les îles Fidji puis
Tahiti c'était chouette de d'embarquer
comme ça sur un bâtiment militaire on
est marin mais on embarque pas
finalement donc on a vraiment pu voir
comment se passer la vie à bord
parce que c'était d'être un marin
embarqué finalement et il a joué après
d'arriver sur des îles comme ça pour
partager la musique c'est quand même une
très belle expérience
pour Yuna le baguette est une affaire de
famille son frère l'a intégré la même
année mais à chacun son instrument le
matelot Gwenaëlle joue de la bombarde
on joue en famille on s'offrir et sœurs
au sein du bagad paraît le plaisir de
partager ça justement à deux parce que
c'est des déjà que le fait de jouer au
bagad de landuo c'est une expérience en
elle-même mais le faire à deux en
famille c'est très enrichissant voilà
chacun apporte un petit peu apporter à
l'autre et c'est super expérience ça
fera des super souvenirs je considère ça
donc le fait d'intégrer le bagad comme
un accomplissement musical je pense que
n'importe qui qui commence la musique
tout petit rêve un jour de devenir
musicien professionnel c'est la
continuité de tout mon cursus du
conservatoire et enfin le bagad de
landieux on a un côté traditionnel de
parler des instruments qu'on utilise et
de par les airs qu'on joue après on est
également très ouvert sur tous les
autres styles de musique puisque pendant
notre concert on intègre du piano de la
trompette du saxophone de la guitare
basse et les compositions effectuées par
les musiciens du groupe sont quand même
très influencés par tous les musiques
actuelles
l'aventure du bagad démarrant en 1952
sur la base d'aéronautique navale de
lambioué près de Lorient dans le
Morbihan à l'origine un maître principal
assorti une bombarde de sa poche et à
commencer à jouer un air breton petit à
petit d'autres musiciens l'ont rejoint
et c'est ainsi que c'est créé le bagad
[Musique]
être à la tête du bagad c'est
enrichissant humainement c'est c'est
valorisant c'est une aventure
extraordinaire une aventure humaine
extraordinaire
et puis c'est aussi une découverte même
si je suis bretonne j'ai quand même
appris malgré tout plein de choses ce
que fait le baguette c'est une musique
populaire et c'est vrai que les gens
viennent facilement vers les jeunes déjà
peut-être parce qu'ils sont jeunes je ne
sais pas et les musiciens se prêtent
beaucoup à cela il y a aucun problème
ils aiment parler de leur musique ils
aiment expliquer ce qu'ils font et ils
aiment beaucoup être en prestation et
ils aiment beaucoup justement avoir
cette possibilité de répondre aux
questions après une prestation ici prête
volontiers et ben c'est très agréable
parce qu'on a le contact directement
avec le public les gens viennent dès
qu'ils entendent de la musique les gens
reviennent nous écouter et il y a un
rapport qui a pas forcément dans une
salle où on est sur scène donc il y a
plus de distance peut-être avec les
spectateurs là on est vraiment au sein
de la foule au sein de l'Armada on les
gens sont contents qu'on soit là
[Musique]
en musique elle est bien
ritée aussi c'est la première fois que
je viens de voir l'Armada et la musique
avec c'est merveilleux
c'est plus agréable que les enceintes et
la musique
[Musique]
il y a de la planète je suppose ça
change les multiples bretonne bon c'est
c'est nouveau c'est nos voisins c'est
c'est
interpelle ça donne envie de s'arrêter
ouais ouais c'est agréable
vous connaissez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]